sooo mosh jennamarbles jacksepticeye
pewdiepie so many questions about these
youtubers but the real question here is
what dog
Microsoft made this website it's with
science and future technology with
science and future technology with
science and future technology
Microsoft has managed to create a
website that changes people's lives a
website that it Texans what job
first of all let's check out its if this
no I didn't Google sexy that's this is
Bing that's this Bing and good old Bing
being weird okay don't worry about that
it's so Edgar bug alright well it would
be a total [ __ ] fail if we can't
detect that Edgar as a pug you did it
look at that Edgar what's that post you
actually love me oh god no very
interesting okay so now that we know
that it's legit let's [ __ ] with it first
of all me am i a dog I am a Shetland
Sheepdog strong barker hey I can roll
with that
what about jacksepticeye great
absolutely athleticism whatever intense
stares
yeah you got that right highly
intelligent I'm sorry what about Marzia
irish settler great jogging this thing
is hilarious
don't kill me my tan so it detects any
face like is that it what about how far
can we stretch this Basenji now I can't
really say that I see the resemblance
not gonna lie I don't think it's there I
am not finding any dogs but I don't
really mind Oh God Oh
miniature I wouldn't really call that
miniature oh my god oh my god it looks
the same what the [ __ ]
german shepherd dog can't say I see it
can't say I see it now but if I go long
or strike German Shepherd I'm starting
to see a resemblance between the memes
perhaps a conspiracy theory Oh
god
ah I'm so sick of the Illuminati jokes
but this [ __ ] rides itself alright I
can't really help it
so what happens then if we put a German
Shepherd dog No
why
now
I don't believe it we've been supplying
Eggert we've been so blind now what
happens if we combine two phases for
science
so if me and Edgar has babies it's gonna
be a boxer
good to know buddy good to know too bad
we cut your balls off oh my god what if
the [ __ ] am i lookin at ya oh god no
dogs found well good because I'm pretty
sure that's a demon what the [ __ ] is
this what is wrong with people
stop what what the what I guess I guess
pokemons aren't dogs that's something we
learn today I suppose wait so dogs are
dogs too what I don't
is everything dogs all right first thing
is so much for watching this video if
you enjoyed please leave a like
subscribe to come abroad today thank you
so much for watching and I will see you
tomorrow with another video as always
stay awesome
oh why do they hate me so much what did
I do